They're really clever. They have
these amazing cognitive abilities.
They're more like feathered apes.
This is Betty, she's a female raven.
She's the biggest of the corvids.
And corvids in general are
very, very intelligent birds.
They can creatively problem-solve.
So they can put together sequences
or behaviours that they've learned
into a novel way to solve a problem.
You see she'll look at things,
she'll cock her head,
and you can actually
see her working it out.
What is it?
Can I benefit anything from that?
The hard part is trying to stay
one step in front of her.
So there's a classic military line
that says improvise, adapt, overcome.
And that's a really positive way
of thinking about anything.
It's about trial and error and
the resilience to keep going.
New Caledonian crows
create multi-step tools,
which are essentially tools that
are strong and thick at one end
and thin and flexible
at the other end.
And that means that they are able to
put those tools easily into crevices
and extract food items.
Albert Einstein described
compound interest
as the eighth wonder of the world.
Crows really understand
compound interest.
So when they save that bit of food
and bury it in the grass,
they know that over time
maggots will come in
and, from the crow's perspective,
they will have even more food.
It's found its food,
it's saved its food,
and now it's buried it
in the ground somewhere
where it gets compound
interest on its investment.
She's burying food in the summer,
you've got files, flies lay eggs,
maggots hatch out the eggs.
So when she goes back to the food,
not only has she got the rotten bit
of food she's cached anyway,
but she's doubled it in size by
having all the maggots on it as well.
For a long time it was thought
that delayed gratification
was something that was unique
to humans and non-human great apes
and some primates,
but it has been found that
corvids will delay gratification.
So they will deny themselves
an immediate reward
in order to get a reward
of a better quality in the future.
They form really
long-term relationships,
and those relationships
are themselves
an example of delayed gratification.
Crows have absolutely nailed
delayed gratification.
There's a seminal book, called The
Marshmallow Test, by Walter Mischel,
which studies young children
and as they've grown up
and their ability to
delay gratification,
their ability to look at
a marshmallow and wait,
and if they wait long
enough they will get two.
What that study showed is that those
children were able, later on in life,
to be better at managing money,
better at managing relationships,
healthier, more likely to do
exercise, more likely to eat well.
So delayed gratification is the key
to putting off those short-term
gains for long-term benefits.
No. No.